le thuel simpson participe pour la
seconde fois au salon des métiers d'art
de rambouillet s'est uni monteyne s'est
lancée dans la peinture sur porcelaine
depuis deux ans j'ai une clientèle qui
commence à se faire en fait ça fait deux
ans que je suis installé à en tant que
peintre sur porcelaine et je recherche
vraiment des vrais salon des métiers
d'art qui correspondent en fait à mon
activité
ce week-end s'étaient donné rendez-vous
tourneur sur bois verrier ou encore
couturier les intempéries de la semaine
dernière n'ont pas refroidi les
visiteurs la qualité des artisans est
absolument impressionnante enfin ils
sont a priori ce que je vois c'est
vraiment très très joli très bien fait
très très très beau donc je pense qu'on
revienne
on est venu ce matin par curiosité par
pure curiosité donc pour voir un peu ce
qui pouvait se faire en terme
d'innovation sur les différentes
matières ce salon a aussi un but
caritatif tous les bénéfices sont
reversés à l'association l'étoile de
martin la première casquette c'est de
financer le matériel pour la recherche
des enfants qui sont atteints du cancer
et là sa deuxième casquette c'est de
leur permettre quand ils sont à
l'hôpital de passer le temps plus
rapidement en prenant déprécie gieter en
prenant des clowns pour cette quatrième
édition le salon a réuni une quarantaine
d'exposants